10x has made my life better 2x is
difficult how do you 2x like how how do
you actually double something the 10x
concept is this I'm here and I'm going
to go up here and it's going to be so
impossible that it causes you to think
different it's not that you achieve this
it causes you to think different
strategize different look at different
assets look at different uh mechanisms
change your way of thinking see most
people try to do this they're trying to
go from something from here to something
logical and the problem with that is
only logic can be used in this
evaluation but when you start thinking
about 10 times your income let's say
let's say you're making 100,000 lb a
year and you're like and 100,000s hard
and you're like man I just hit the
100,000 level and you're like oh my God
I can't believe I'm doing 100,000 so
what the the individual does now is he's
like man if I could just do that again
next year okay and he's trying to
maintain what he did there's no creating
that there's no new Solutions there's no
new ideas in that so you start thinking
about 10x it makes you it forces you to
think different than what got you right
here hey it's EV car Michael and I make
these videos because I need them because
being around successful entrepreneurs
who are pushing who are driving who are
doing amazing things gives me that extra
little motivational inspirational boost
in the morning every day to help me go
off and accomplish great things too and
I hope that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's get
some incredible motivation from the one
and only Grant Cardone
enjoy I want to share three things with
you that I truly believe in this
manifest station thing now I'm not that
Voodoo um Law of Attraction guy but I
can tell you images uh pictures locking
in on something looking at uh looking at
other possibilities getting examples of
other people doing things it's so so
valuable I mean it's our first way to
learn is to mimic is to see as babies
are are you know we see our
parents playing with their phones guess
what we want to pick up the phone and
play with the phone we see our parents
typing on a computer the kids want to do
what they want to come type on your
computer they don't even know how to use
it yet it's mimicking it's basically
taking something else somebody has done
boom Boat Boat I want boat okay it's the
way we learn to cook you watch your mom
cook eggs or fry bacon or make oatmeal
and she's got her own recipe guess what
that's the recipe you use so we end up
with all these little twerks and weird
habits uh back in the 50s you know all
all our parents smoked so what happened
when the kids grew up they picked up
smoking and alcohol Etc so the first
thing to do is on the manifestation
thing is you got to have some pictures
right if you don't have those
pictures you know you don't you have
poverty around you you have struggle you
have like I grew up in struggle I didn't
grow up in poverty I grew up in a
struggle even though we had enough okay
it was always this idea that there
wasn't enough even when there was enough
it was crazy even when we had enough
dude it was always this idea that we
didn't have enough and I keep moving
around on this because I want you guys
to see these views they're just
ridiculous beautiful little town of
postano that is filled with
magic okay and for those of you who've
never traveled here or been over this
part of the world man come over here
figure out literally sit down this one
of the things I do first I take a lock
in on a picture bang yacht second thing
I'm going to do is try to get as close
to that thing on the manifestation thing
not the Law of Attraction but the law of
action
okay first I see it then I'm going to
try to get I'm going to close the
distance now it took me 20 years to get
on this this Beast okay but what I can
do in between then and I hope it doesn't
take you 20 years is I'd started
collecting pictures and images okay
until I could actually put my feet on
get as close as you can between you and
the target so if it's a boat a plane uh
a business business ownership an RV car
or whatever it is okay what you want to
do is take pictures of it collect images
of it okay maybe reinforce those by
looking at them often thinking about
them just playing with it don't even
worry about how to get it uh what it's
going to take to get it and the second
thing is to start like get closing the
distance between you and that image
could be pictures could be images could
be research it could be you going to the
car dealership and actually sitting in
the car you know getting an appointment
to go see the house I
remember this is insane to think this
but I remember when I did not
think that I could get somebody to show
me a house I remember when I was like I
was L and I were La I wanted to see this
house it was for sale and I was
concerned that they wouldn't think
enough of me to even let me see the
house so if you guys have ever struggled
with all this limited thinking okay but
later I bought the house I was little
bought the house ended up making on that
house I made like $12 million or
something and I did not think when I
went into the house that I was going to
be able to even see the house so if you
suffer from a self-esteem issue
um
or sense of self or I was telling my
daughter the other day I said man I've
had self-esteem issues my whole life not
thinking I was good enough not thinking
I can get there I'm still doing it
today you know I started thinking about
you know last time I was here 20 years
ago one day I'm going to be on a boat
here in posto now I'm thinking one day
I'm going to be here on my own boat what
do you want to be on okay so number one
okay take a picture of it two close the
distance and three at some point you're
going to have to start doing the math
and the math for me is this what would
it take to buy this what is the
resources the beans the coins the
dollars the energy the output the number
of people I need to make contact with
and if I can't figure that out just
figure this simple math out
how
did uh he do it how
did he do it how did he do it what
business are they
in what did they do to do this how did
they get it and maybe it's just a
charter okay so nothing wrong with that
okay hope you guys do well hope you
figure out some things that really get
rich in your mind about your
manifestations about what you want what
your purpose is what's driving you to
fuel you so you can and your you and
your family can have a great life if you
ever get to post a
tel okay let me know saving money is
stupid it is like it is ridiculous the
only thing that ever happens to people
that save money is they end up losing it
it's end up getting lost it ends up
getting stolen it ends up getting burnt
or it ends up going down in value but
it's never going to get
bigger you save money at the bank it
ain't getting bigger period who does
that benefit we've all been told save
your money save your money save your
money who does that really benefit I I
remember I read the the Blackjack book
how to play blackjack right I knew that
book I knew every card to
hit and then I realized everybody at the
table had read the same damn book
everybody staying on 16s then this
Chinese dude comes in and this freaking
guys banging 16s against nines like like
or 16s against sevens sixes and fives
and fours everything he shouldn't do
he's doing he's splitting tens and I'm
like and he's making all the money he
was the only one not playing by the
book and and so I just think that
there's everybody should buy a house
Maybe
not maybe not okay because the wealthy
guys never talk about the house they
bought Warren Buffett owns one
house so I got a lot of those little
things that you
know that that
that I have just observed in my own
life that that are
just they're just not true man period
we're indoctrinated to believe all this
bull save your money pay off your house
get rid of your debt uh plan for
retirement all that benefits Wall Street
it doesn't benefit you and your family
yeah we're not encouraged to take risk
imagine if America was encouraged in
school at eth grade take risk don't save
money invest it okay buy real estate
that appreciates over 10year period stay
broke do not keep money at your bank do
not fund future emergencies they may
never happen but what do they tell us
you need 90-day reserve for your
personal life 90-day reserve for your
wife 90-day reserve for your parents
90-day reserve for your business and and
and then people start saving money
planning on emergencies that typically
never happen and who benefits the banks
benefit First Republic Bank Silicon
Valley Bank okay Signature Bank they're
all in trouble today what I would tell
people to do is stay broke that's what I
do so I had $50 million worth of debt
then in
2012 and a couple million dollars worth
of uh uh assets today I have $2 billion
worth of debt and $4 billion worth of
assets
uh because I quit saving money and I
quit quit playing the retirement game
and quit playing the uh real estate the
uh the uh stock market game and I quit
gambling I started trusting build my
business number one first of all take
care of me two take care of my
businesses you know we had I think I had
six employees in 2012 I have closer to
650 today also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
when I woke up what I did was I grabbed
a legal pad next to
me and uh I just simply start writing in
present
tense or in past tense but not in future
things that I'd like to accomplish in my
lifetime these are really short notes
like hey let's say let's say the yacht's
on my mind I'd like to own a yacht one
day right or maybe you don't want to own
one you want a Charter One whatever I
would just write down a uh 300t
yacht I don't really have to get
specific at that time about whether I'm
going to own it or Charter it doesn't
really matter to me you could be
specific but I'm just trying to bring my
mind to some attention this is an Ever
almost ever L process except for except
for finding the
notepad and writing this is this does
not require thinking or how to or
mechanics okay so like I might write
okay I want1 ,000 units we're 10,000
12,000 units right now in our real
estate portfolio and I'm like I want to
get to 100,000 units so I'm just going
to write 100,000 plus
units uh what else did I write this
morning see every day I'm doing I'm
doing it really I'm doing it three times
a day I'm doing it morning and I'm doing
it at night and the third time I'll do
it is anytime I have a fail an upset um
a setback some rejection I didn't get
what I wanted then I I will write down
and go right hey hey man yacht I want a
home in Italy I remember I used to write
uh that I wanted a house if you go back
and read the 10x rule you'll hear one of
my notes in there was to own a home in
Florence Italy showed up for a while
okay motorcycles showed up for a while
helicopter showed up for a while but
some of this just comes and goes in the
morning when I'm writing down my goals
it's almost a form of active
meditation okay where I'm just like
literally scanning my mind for ideas of
things I'd like to accomplish in my
lifetime whatever pops up I write it
down this whole exercise maybe last 3
minutes 4 minutes long uh I leave the
writings scribblings if you will uh in
the notepad more often than not when and
when the notepad is full I just simply
throw it in the trash so it's not like
I'm doing
anything that requires any effort here
okay it's quick it's fast it's
easy uh I want a great marriage okay so
boom I'm I'm want great health I don't
know what that looks like exactly what
does great health look like to everybody
I don't know I should grow older it
means different things and then it opens
me up oh I want my 10x Health System I
want to have a million clients on 10x
Health
System uh on uh Cardone Capital 100,000
100,000 units and I want one uh what do
I have 14,000 investors right now
140,000 investors Cardone Equity Group
okay I want to raise a billion dollars
for Cardone Equity Group and
democratize alternative Investments for
everyday people so they're not just
freaking taking advantage of by or
monopolized by Goldman and JP and uh the
cares and the KKR that were all these
big giant
buns see what's happening I'm doing it
right now right I'm just not writing it
down now the significance of writing it
down is it kind of just gets the juices
flowing and I personally find it to be
better when I'm doing
it with ink than if I'm doing it on a
notepad on my phone what are like some
daily habits daily routines that you
have that you've been able to use that
have compounded over the last 15 20
years well the for the the most
important one is waking up man man
making sure you wake up you know um
ideally wake up when you say you're
going to wake up because that's where it
all goes downhill from there like make a
decision when you're when you're going
to go to sleep at night and when you're
going to wake up I was talking to Tom
Brady about this I mean he's he controls
what time he goes to bed right so that
that that's when he controls when he
puts himself
down and you know if I if I had known
that when I was a kid 17 18 years old I
I wouldn't have got 90% of the trouble
that I got in I would have never gotten
in trouble because nothing bad
everything bad happens happened to me
after nine o00 right like almost nothing
bad happened to me during the day right
um and um so one you know pick a time to
go to sleep boom go down get a good
night of rest yep rest is really
important I was I was watching something
Elon was talking about the other day
about he's got to get six hours less
than that he's he's getting less done
during the day and I know a lot of
people out there are pitching 4 a.m. in
the mornings and that might be good for
training at physical training or what
hunting or some other stuff that you're
doing but in business man I need to be
clear I need rest as you age you're
going to need more rest uh I had a
shoulder injury recent recently so I'm
actually trying to get more sleep right
now not less uh to to recuperate from
that um sometimes it takes longer as you
get older so one I wake up in the
morning dude rested two the second thing
I want to do is I want to go get a
workout in third thing I want to give my
recovery time in like I'm I'm I'm again
I had to add some things as you is
things change as life Chang you add
stuff so uh then I come to the office
and you know somebody tells me what to
do for the rest of the
day uh there's one thing that I do do in
there that's a ritual that uh every
morning I get a um I think I got it yeah
yeah um I've looked at this thing so
often now that every morning I get a
report of where our cash accounts are
every cash account that we have kpis say
again
you got those kpis the key performance
indicators coming in the cash accounts
and know yeah yeah yeah yeah that that
that that's more just a like more than a
kpi it's in this case it's I want to see
where the dough is now and there might
be I've been doing this for a long time
now I remember doing this when the
account was
zero and my goal by the way is to get
the account to zero so I'm gonna look at
my cash accounts and I'm going look at
assets that I'm moving cash into right
because what I'm trying to do is
accumulate assets not cash they asked me
a question today that I want to talk
about they're like dude how are
you everybody we talk to talks about
being nice to their people taking care
of their people doing this for their
people why is it the the the answer you
have is different I said what do you
mean well it seems like you're hard on
people I said no man I'm not being hard
on
people I'm just trying to take care of
my
environment I'm not trying I I don't
practice being a a a a
d I'm trying to take care of my
environment my decisions are about my
environment right so little Grant little
Grant's this this little phone right
here this is little Grant he got issues
he needs to clean up his issues Grant's
got to get hard on Grant okay you you
guys out there y'all y'all so soft on
your people it's cuz you're soft on
yourself right that's why you you end up
with no money you end up with people
betraying you you end up with people
taking advantage of you even your kids
don't appreciate you do you got to be
hard on yourself I'm hard on everybody
around me but mostly I'm hard on me
study two multimillionaires do
not take heed to this do not study a
millionaire once a person becomes a
millionaire the first thing they do
unfortunately is go into conservation to
protect the million study
multi-millionaires study people that
have consistently developed impr proven
because of tens or 20s or 30s or
hundreds of millions of dollars that
they've accumulated that they have the
right practice the right diff discipline
and they're still expanding you don't
need 22 mentors study two people deep
that have gotten it right study two
people so deep rather than 20 people
shallow I promise you it'll make a
difference if you get a chance to spend
three days with anybody that's
accumulated 30 40 50 $100 million I'll
promise you it's a game changer so put
that on your bucket list I'm going to
spend 3 days with a multi-millionaire in
an environment where I can learn from
them it will be a game Cher for you and
also limit your study to two people not
22 people that will create you from
having conflictive uh data and content
and information what's your best advice
to anybody when it comes to scaling a
business what's your secret to scaling
dude you got to scale there there's not
an option but I I hear other people say
oh not everybody should scale if you
don't scale you're not going to you have
nothing you don't have a business you're
basically somebody
else's probably even your own like
there's no such thing as being the boss
just so you guys know the smaller the
company is the more you are really the
more the more controlled you are the
more you know if you have three
employees they're going to push you
around even though you're writing the
checks if you have 30 customers they're
going to push you around because you
don't have you can't lose customers you
got to scale so that you can lose
customers you have to scale your
employees so that you can like you're
never dependent upon an employee you
know if you have three employees you got
a problem you got 30 employees you still
have a problem if you got 3,000
employees you don't have a problem right
you don't have a problem you don't have
3,000 problems you have a manager or two
that has 3,000 problems but you don't
have them anymore that's why you got to
scale so my first business couldn't
scale it just it was in a very tiny
vertical and I was I was the authority
in the vertical I was the king of the
vertical so it appeared on paper that I
was doing good compared to how my dad
did or my grandparents I was doing
phenomenal but it was not scalable
couldn't sell it couldn't exit it I had
to do everything and now we're in 10x
Health that thing's scalable to the
hundreds of billions of dollars uh we're
in real estate I've raised a billion
dollars in cash there that building the
business has got $5 billion worth of
real estate that could go to 10 billion
50 billion it could go to 100 billion
Like There's No Limit as much as I can
imagine as long as I can add good people
it can it can grow and scale there
number one dude I would not hang around
any losers no dead beats no bad credit
people nobody that can't take care of
their car people with drug and alcohol
problems leave them all alone okay they
can't get through their classes they
want to skip uh they want to add time to
everything they're creating problems in
their life for their parents for their
brothers and sisters leave them alone
follow people that are connected number
two thing I would do different I would
go follow the connected people sometimes
they're the most boring that's who I'd
go follow man where their parents are in
good shape they belong to Country clubs
I know I know it's not comfortable for
you guys if you came up the way I did
but I would go hang with those people
get connected with them no matter how
uncomfortable third thing I would not
follow my talents or my passion I would
follow the money I would follow
opportunity okay I would go look at
things that could actually pay off for
me when I'm 30 and 40 not do the things
that feel good when I'm 20 four I would
I would make a decision to get super
rich I know you guys hear me talk about
money all the time man man you can you
can there's not one of you that's seeing
this right now that couldn't get super
super super super Bezos Elon musr if you
focused on it you could okay you just
have to focus on it okay if you can make
your health better if I come in this gym
every day and work out I'm going to get
in better shape there's no person that
does not come to this gym I mean maybe a
quarter of 1% of all people on the
planet have some kind of physical issue
that if they came in here nothing would
change otherwise if I come in here I
don't care how how old you are 65 25 15
5 years old you come in the gym every
day you're going to rip out at some
point okay more work you put in more
you're going to get out of it same thing
with money if you wanted to get super
rich and you weren't brought up the way
I was to just settle compromise be
comfortable be grateful I'm grateful for
what I have dude if I would have gone
for Super Rich when I was 20 I would be
I would be mega mega Rich today can you
listen to the excuses of your employees
and salese I have 100 sales people in
one one one city and I I'm just losing
my patience yeah to to list they would
never they would never talk around me
with it I
mean the environment wouldn't allow it
no there's no way anybody would be like
I'm late
because of the traffic they they know
they're going to get punched in the face
I didn't make
appointments because there there's no
way like we we have a
culture uh we have 92 employees or
something at our office and um last time
we spoke you had 60 yeah no we we we
could we could use 200 we could use 200
right now so
um we uh I mean I don't think we would
ever hear that would we Jared I didn't
hit my numbers because uh most most most
yeah I mean it's it's just not tolerated
like responsib it's not we don't even
talk about don't use excuses it's just
the environment cult cuz they don't hear
me making excuses
so like if I miss a deal we we we do a
lot of real estate deals so if I miss a
deal I'm always going to what did I do
wrong in that deal first response for me
is what did I do wrong in that deal that
they didn't pick me MH what did I do
wrong that I didn't get that deal what
did we do wrong that we didn't hit our
number there like I I'm never saying
he's not blaming somebody well I don't
have control when I blame I want control
so even if they are to blame right I
want control I'm not going to ass you
blame if you hit my car I'm going to I'm
going to say what did I do wrong what
did I do that allowed you to hit my car
I did something so even in the most dumb
dumb like I I ended up in a lawsuit
where a guy basically found something
sued me for it I didn't do anything to
this
dude my immediate response was what did
I do to create that
frivolous situation he was a criminal
total Criminal me for 60 million bucks
he just sued me cuz he he thought he
could get something from it but but I
did something and the reason I want to
assume
that what the cause I want to be the
cause point is because if I assume that
position even though I didn't really do
anything um then I can control what I
did I can't control what another person
does but I can spend time and energy
controlling what I
did so when if me and Elena getting an
argument you know when I'm rational I'm
like hey what did I do did I not give
pay enough attention what did I do to
cause that situation did I respond wrong
in a wrong
fashion and and I screw up all the time
when to buy something stupid because
there's going to come a time in life
JayZ just bought a $200 million house
dude he can do whatever he wants to do
he's worth $2 and a half billion dollar
okay I don't know that it was the
smartest thing to do but he can do it
when do you do something stupid you just
got a contract for uh uh for $50 million
as an athlete when do you do something
stupid it ain't now I guarantee you just
cuz you got a score doesn't mean you
should go spend start buying houses and
cars and [__] okay this is when you
should do something stupid okay how
stupid can you go I'm going play a
little song for you here that my team
created for you okay number one number
one number one most important thing when
you do something stupid you need to be
able to pay
cash not that you will pay cash but you
need to be in a position to pay cash for
that thing if you cannot pay cash let's
say I just got a contract for $12
million as an athlete I got a movie deal
I got Advanced $4 million okay and
they're going to pay me the other $4
million when the movie finishes uh I'm a
sales guy and I just got a big
commission for 200 Grand okay uh I I
sold my company I picked up 10 million
whatever you got a score okay you would
think oh I can do something stupid right
now you don't have your cash yet so if
you don't have your cash yet you ain't
going to do it yet CU you ain't got cash
if you can't pay for it in cash don't do
it doesn't mean you will pay for it in
cash it means you have enough cash to do
it number two you need to have twice the
amount of
cash or you need to buy two of them be
able to buy two of them not that you
would but this will give you assurance
that you're not keeping things too tight
so let's say I find a watch I want to
buy a watch is 50 Grand I have to say I
can pay cash for the watch and I need to
be able to buy two of them in order to
say it's cool to do it that will tell me
that I'm Ready the third thing the third
filter here is this money these number
one and number two cash and twice has to
come from passive income this is going
to eliminate probably
10 x okay the purchases that you make CU
most people simply do not have earn a
passive income so if you're a ball
player and they said hey we're going to
give you $50 million you don't start
buying houses my mama wants a house good
can you buy her two of them the house is
$2 million you got a $50 million
contract that's earned income watch this
my mama wants a house that's $2 million
okay can you buy two of them yeah you
can check check but here's the deal it's
not passive income you're not ready to
do this yet oo this is hard man why you
showing me this grant why you waking me
up to this because I'm trying to tell
you how to create wealth and never be
broke I want to share with you the five
five benefits of real estate over stocks
and bonds number one and you cannot deny
this tangible asset real estate is a
physical very often very difficult to
replace asset it offers a sense of
security and the potential for
appreciation over long periods of time
unlike stocks pieces of paper and bonds
or even cash savings accounts or money
markets uh real estate is a tangible
asset as opposed to intangible real
estate investment give you the investor
direct control over a real asset number
two cash flow there is no asset gold
silver Bitcoin bonds are stocks that
cash flow like real estate real estate
Investments typically provide a
consistent and even monthly passive
income for the passive investor from
Riddle income which offers you a regular
source of cash flow for your investors
and by the way cash flow is what your
family depends on okay whether you're
working or not you need cash flow number
three diversification real estate
Investments offer a great
diversification from traditional stocks
and bonds and potentially reduces
somebody's overall portfolio risk in
fact I'm so uh bullish on real estate
going forward that I actually have more
of my diversification across my asset
classes because of the number of doors
and different properties that I own in
different states that's right you can
actually take real estate and have
diversification because of location and
scale number four inflation head
for thousands of years real estate has
proved to be a great hedge against
inflation that we're in right now
meaning real estate generally maintains
or increases their value over time
beyond the cost of living Rises number
five in the mac daddy okay now I
wouldn't do this without the other four
but tax benefits of real estate are like
none other there is no comparison
anywhere in the world real estate offers
the best tax advantages deductions for
marget interest property taxes uh rehab
capex like it is endless including
accelerated depreciation which is
literally wiped out in many years my
income tax bill is zero look it's worth
noting that every investment as you know
has some kind of risk but if you want
the biscuit you got to risk it and the
best risk for me is to never lose my
money to get cash flow to get
appreciation to get leverage and to get
the tax writeoffs and they ain't but one
thing that sounds like that and it's
it's called real EST estate get invested
today as they say don't wait and invest
in real estate buy real estate and wait
buying real estate is really a sales job
it's not really a buyer's job so in the
beginning when I was buying real estate
I had everything backwards I thought I
needed the money then I thought I needed
the debt I didn't know anything about
either one of them and then I put the
deal third today we just switched it hey
man it's the deal the deal the right
deal will always bring in the right debt
there'll be somebody be like I'll be the
debt on that deal and the bigger these
deals by the way the bigger the deals
the easier the deals get like the debt
the easier the Deb everything gets
easier like a 10,000 units would be
easier for me to purchase than 1,000 a
Reit would be even easier for me to buy
we've had those phone calls this week it
would be easier for me to buy a Reit
even though I don't know where to get
$10 billion or 5 billion it would be
easier for me to buy a Reit than it
would be for for me to buy a
portfolio so none of us are told this
unfortunately because uh maybe there's
an agenda to keep people small so it's
the deal is the debt once you have the
deal and the debt together dude the
equity not not not even a problem
there's no shortage of money that will
follow a great deal so this is the last
point because you said this on a show
that requires a Salesman not a buyer you
got to learn how to pitch you got to
learn how to talk to people you got to
learn how to pull people in you got to
learn how to get attention and I don't
mean salesman in a bad way more probably
a better is a promoe to learn how to
promote and raise money number three
rule know exactly what your cost of
living is it is shocking to me how many
people absolutely have no idea how much
income they make how much their taxes
are how much their house payment their
car payment their electric their water
their utilities what they're spending on
their kids eating out chipotes ubering
like you don't know if you don't know
you can't control what you're doing okay
so the first thing you do is got to know
exactly where every single penny is
going what are your kids getting what is
your wife spending what are you spending
what does gas cost you oil cost you
tires cost you count it all if you
simply take the last 90 days and look
through your checkbook and your credit
cards and you just total all that up
that is your cost of living okay take
that divide by three and that's what
it's costing you to live every month you
need to know that down to a nickel know
exactly what your cost of living is so
that you can start one controlling that
and number two outgrow that and the
beginning if you just go back to
February March this year I would told my
whole team I said guys we're getting
ready to go into one of the hardest
deepest ugliest nastiest recessions I've
ever experienced in my 60 years and
everybody's like oh my God here he goes
you know I'm like I'm telling you I'm
not and I'm not a silver gold bitcoin's
gonna go away World's Gonna end the
world never ends yeah this is the most
painful thing you know that I've
learned in four recessions is that you
always Sur survive them but but that's
the bad news you know you you'll get
through it you will get through it you
but most people unfortunately are going
to be a statistic because of it uh and
and the big problem is most people move
too slowly to accept what's going on so
in the beginning they lied to us they've
redefined the word recession they also
did that vaccine uh they're they're
going to redefine what the economy is by
by the time they've redefined
unemployment numbers those are probably
at 10% today they report three uh
they're lying about inflation today
we're already past the inflation bubble
problem we're we're probably in
deflation now not
inflation and uh the issue is not if
they're going to Li if they've lied to
us is how many times had they lied to
you and the way to find that out is to
Simply ask yourself is your family doing
better or not 64% of all small
businesses in America there's 32 million
of them Break Even or lose
money uh 70 70% somewhere between 68 and
76% of all
Americans uh live paycheck to paycheck
and half of all people that make a 100
Grand a year in this country live
paycheck to paycheck so th those things
tell me you cannot have 330 million
people in an educated developed Nation
where information's available to
everyone you can't have that many stupid
people in one place okay that means that
means to me they're not Americans are
not lazy Americans are not stupid we're
not you know we have we have data dude
most of us have computers and phones so
why are so many people suffering it's
because we have
been doctrinated to benefit Wall Street
and the
banks and it's time that people say okay
and it's happening right now people are
starting to wake up social media is
actually waking the world up I think
what's going on in in the last three or
four years since covid and the election
Co us sending $200 billion to Ukraine
like people are starting to wake up and
say wait a minute something's going on
and I don't know if it's it's in my best
interest so we're going to go into a
very difficult recession we're in one
already they'll tell us later that we
were and businesses are going to go out
of business uh househ holes are going to
find out that they they don't have the
money they don't have enough savings
they don't have enough Investments
they're going to find out their cash is
worthless they're going to have to
struggle this year in 2023 with with
even maintaining their business or
growing it but there's Silver Lining
here okay Silver Lining is during
recessions is when people can actually
grow if they have the strategies because
there's fewer people to to to
participate and compete
with so there's the bad news man the
good news is I'm going to grow there's
three great pivots I've had in my career
and they all came on the tail of a
recession I believe I'm a spiritual
being Not a Human Being the spiritual
being would have tremendous potential
unbelievable potential it would be the
light on the candle not the candle the
body would be the candle okay and and
the spiritual being would be the flame I
I'm not I'm I'm the flame and and I want
to see how hot can I burn okay how far
can I go how much light can I bring the
world how much positive truth message
can I bring this
planet
how much more can I do and I think the
problem is people are settling out with
just enough pay the bills take care of
my family get my little box get my
little house put my little welcome mat
on the front put the little gate around
the yard we're all going to be happy I
don't want the box I don't want one
location I don't need the welcome at I
want to know the world I want to travel
the world I want to do more I want to be
in more places I want to have friends in
every country I want to inspire people
in every language and I want other
people to seeing they can do the same
thing you know and and and maybe maybe
maybe at the end of all this I just
become everybody's uncle that I never
had saving money is ridiculous you guys
shouldn't save your money you should
take your money like this is what I the
game I've been playing since I was 31
years old and nobody knew I was doing it
I was calling on you guys getting money
from you and you were funding all my
real
estate and that's why I was hustling so
hard I was doing 300 days a year I'd get
five grand from you four grand n grand
three grand two grand on any given day
the price could have been anything you
know if I needed a real estate deal I'd
call you guys hey man buy some of my sh
you know well what is it this week oh
it's a g-pod you know any anybody buy a
g-pod from me g-pod was basically
basically what a gpod was it was a apple
came out with that little the little
tiny thing Nano Nano yeah the Nano so I
took all my video
put it on the Nano and called it a
g-pod this in 2010 man half of you guys
were out of business okay I said you got
to get the g-pod the new gpod man all my
videos are on the gpod right and so some
of you guys would buy it I'd take the
nine grand and I invest the entire 9,000
in real estate all of it always broke
never had any money didn't have fancy
cars or Gucci or nothing I wasn't
traveling anytime i' travel I'd come
travel to you I'd go up to Winnipeg and
Thanksgiving cuz we didn't have
Thanksgiving in Winnipeg the Canadians
don't do that there so I'd go there pick
up a bag come back buy some American
Real Estate and just buried in a real
estate and stay broke all the time I
want to know how can I Shadow work
someone like you if I would need to
pitch you join The Mastermind why
haven't you done that honestly yeah
honestly yeah why haven't you it's not
me you doubt so what is
it um
you guys understand that any of you that
have not signed up for that it's not me
you
doubt like you can you can you can try
to make it about me but it's not me it's
you it's you you guys doubt you you guys
doubt yourselves you understand you are
so far ahead of where I was when I was
21 years old I was 21 years old I was
getting pistol
whipped I was eating
tranquilizers amphetamines and had my
face on a mirror all day long
like I was a wreck I was a disgrace to
my family and to myself okay she's
21 but you got you guys can learn the
hard way you can learn the fast way so I
can learn by Theory I need to actually
feel when I'm looking at you in this
event yeah I see promoting I come to
work for me you want to come work if you
don't want to join The Mastermind guys
come to work for me but come work for me
every day you want to Shadow me come
work in my office get a salary you get
paid something move across the country
like how else you want to do it I I
can't you want to hang out with me every
day oh no I won't okay I mean I like
like I got a life and I got business
right so like we got we got to figure
out what that is the way to do it the
way to do it is to study people okay if
you guys want to learn the game you got
to study someone and you got to go deep
on one person you can't just like look
at everything that comes your way you
got to study just like you have interior
design if you over if you overthink
let's say I'm a THX right now and you're
not prepared for that type of wealth or
pressure or experience or opportunity
then is that too bay too fast no you
should you should still think bigger
because you're not going to know
thinking smaller right you're not going
to know you're not never going to get
there right I mean look the guy thinks
too small and he wins a billion dollar
lottery ticket and he got lucky he's got
problems too he's just got new problems
he doesn't know what to do with the
money right so I if I would have thought
bigger I I don't have the problem of not
taking action okay so I'm not I'm not
that guy I'm not you you got to deal
with whatever you got right but but I
know this if I thought smaller I would
have taken fewer actions when you start
thinking really big you got you you have
to if you're going to go get this thing
if you're serious about whatever that
thing
is I didn't think I thought here because
I I I thought I was thinking oh yeah
that's
achievable but how can I like how can a
child a three-year-old think that they
can pick
up um 100 pound or ride a big horse they
can't it's like not achievable until
Daddy picks him up puts him on it and
he's like oh I can ride a horse you know
I can ride it but but he when he's
looking up he's like I can't do that
yeah right so when you're looking for
you don't have anything you're just
hungry it's hard to dream man yeah cuz
cuz your stomach's saying pay attention
to me or pay attention to my kids or
shoes or whatever whatever your your
your crunch oh inflation cost of bananas
this is this this is a feier cycle man
this is like like it it it's them
marketing fear to us to stay small so we
become consumers not
doers consumers are worried about
inflation okay investors want inflation
producers want inflation business owners
want inflation okay if you got a career
and you got a talent ball players want
inflation if you own a sports team you
want inflation if you own real estate
you want inflation but we're being told
it's it's bad why because they're
treating you they're messaging to you as
a
consumer uh social media is bad for you
it is bad for a consumer it's not bad
for a Creator right see see what I'm
saying so I'm trying to get on the the
cause Point The Source Point of like
okay I should have been thinking about
how do I build a $50 billion business 15
years ago a 100% really 100
billion okay what would you have done
differ I would have studied hundred
billion doll businesses who did that I
should have been studying Jamie Diamond
this whole time I should have been
studying Warren what did they do not
what do they say in their bull
interviews because I've I've seen these
guys on panels and then I've had dinner
with them right and bro it's two
different conversations they speak
differently oh
yeah well one one's for the one's for
the Graham you know one's for the
audience for the for the clip and the
other is like hey let's go let's go
carve this deal up this is how we make
money in here how big could this get
they're always talking about how big can
you scale this thing if you want to stay
in the middle class you know good if
that's your goal in life to be in the
middle of anything I'm not peanut butter
I don't really want to be I've already I
grew up in the middle the middle middle
of a crowd does not seem like conducive
to my survivability I don't want my kids
to be middle kids I don't want I want to
be man I want to I want to take my
family to the top so if you want to be
in the middle pay your debt off you want
to get to the top learn to use debt yeah
cuz cuz in in all you know and I think
Dave would be open to this conversation
I know I would be I I'm open to being
wrong Goldman Sachs a worried about debt
JP margan is not worried about debt Elon
Musk is not worried about debt they have
debt they use debt Apple computer has
debt Apple computer has $200 billion in
cash and they borrow money today why is
that because they want to use they want
their cash
reserves on their balance sheet knowing
debt is not the debt is not the devil
okay bad debt using debt to buy a Gucci
belt well that's just stupidity you know
uh but using debt to buy
building they provides me with income
not a house by the way I own two homes
buying homes are bad deals yeah buying a
home is a terrible deal yeah putting
debt on a home is even stupider than
buying the house itself I own but I own
two houses like I'm not telling you guys
I don't do stupid stuff I got these I
don't know what these are don't these
these shoes are stupid no reason for
anybody to buy these shoes I don't even
know why I have them on my feet right
now they're not even that comfortable
they're probably 800 1,200 bucks or
something stupid if you're on the come
up that's dumb can't write it off
they're too much money definitely don't
put a credit card on them but on good
debt it pays me okay like I bought a
house in Malibu I paid cash but I'm
still I still have the cost of that
money right that that spent $40 million
there I could be earning 5% that's $2
million a year in 10 years that 2
million times 10 years I need to make 20
million on that house just to break even
on the cost of money and the purchase
that that's not maintenance property
taxes Furnishing the house or fixing it
I don't really use the word hustle and
grind no I use the word Prosper yeah I'm
not going to work to work I'm going to
work to prosper I don't I don't go I'm
not trying to hustle yeah or grind I
know those are you know I don't want to
grind dude I I want I want to prosper
want score what you do no I want to
score I don't know that I want to enjoy
like my wife she wants to enjoy I don't
think about enjoyment I mean I do but I
think about you know I think about I
want to I want to win the game I want to
I'm playing the game to win the game so
whether it's a big deal we're looking at
a we're looking at $300 million with the
real estate right now in in in uh the US
to close to close by the third quarter
of this year I am very financially
motivated I've never denied
it I say it probably one time a day
extremely financially motivated I love
the idea of measuring thing based on
financial
windfalls
um when we did the Miami Marlin stadium
it had nothing to do with money it was
34,000 people they're like dude that's a
lot of damn people how you going to do
that nobody thought about it damn he
going to make a bunch of money people
actually did not think about how much
money I was going to make make it the
deal they're
thinking how's he going to do that how
the hell you put
34,000 Marlin stadium has never ever had
34,000 people in it maybe not in an
entire foot uh baseball season so so uh
Derek Jeter when I told the owner I was
going to do this he he he was like the
story goes like this I said I walked in
I see the place I said Derek how many
people what's the most people have ever
been here 26,000 who did that Joel
ostein I said fck it then how many
people how many people every seat in the
house 26,000 I said good how many on the
field he's like another six or 7,000
he's like we've never we never loaded up
the field I said bro that field is
bigger than than than uh what is it 11
players 10 players whatever nine players
whatever I'm like I want the whole place
I'm gonna put
34,000 people in this place we put
35,000 people in there he's like what
weekend you want it I said just give me
a price I know it's available the
weekend I want it and he's like but what
weekend I said said just give me a
price I said I guarantee you it's
available the weekend I want it and then
I told him Super Bowl weekend he's like
what are you
crazy I told Steve Harvey Steve come
speak at this deal for a couple hours
when is the Grant I said you available I
said you're gonna fly from Atlanta
because I know you're at the Super Bowl
you're gonna come down to Miami I'm gon
pay for the jet I'm gonna send you back
for the game he's like
what are you crazy dude you cannot do
this on Super Bowl weekend
and so the reason we did that and the
reason it was so important for me to
pull that off is because everyone I knew
that
weekend you you could hate my guts like
despise
me and you had to take your hat off to
me because you can't you can't say you
know the haters came out and said the
sound was
bad okay all right yeah you know but
there but every seat was packed so you
know some things you do
because it might not have a financial
return but trust me it made it easier to
sell out every event we did after that
you know when I was growing up I I
didn't I didn't see a map
of places where you could go and spend
time in the ocean and the waterers you
know
65° and blue and beautiful you have your
wife on jet skis and you can spend a ni
on this yacht charter and spend two
weeks on it or you can figure out how to
buy it nobody was telling me that stuff
now once I get out here you know they
say we're creatures of our environment
you believe that post yes I am a
creature of my environment what kind of
environment you want to be
in uh that's about uh 2,000 gross tons
behind me the boat I'm on is
1170 and they're all over the place okay
it's not like there's one boat out here
it's not like there's one successful
person out here all these people did
something to put this together and When
I See This what I start thinking is wow
if they can do this then I can do this
you got to keep your your your eye on
the ball what is the target for you and
your company while everybody else gets
distracted what's the target go get the
Target in 2010 when I got hammered I'm
like this is never going to happen to me
again I am going to be a big player they
don't don't jack with big players they
Jack with everybody else they leave big
guys alone I'm not a big guy yet but I
can get there I know I can get there you
can't get there if you keep thinking
small you can pay off your cars and you
can pay off your house and your bicycles
and your kids are going to get a good
education but trust me you guys are
still going to be
worried when you retire okay you're
you're we have been indoctrinated to
feed the beast I wrote about this in the
10x rule Feed the Beast not their Beast
you're beast and so what I do is I go
hustle Brad I go Hustle the marketplace
for money you guys see me hustling every
day hit the link come to this go to that
buy this get this every dollar that
comes in I pay my bills and anything
left over I dump it into a real estate
deal and I go hustle again I'm always
broke I never have any dough on me if I
have dough I'm trying to get it in real
estate deal where I'm Ill liquid nobody
can get the money from me and I go bounc
back into the marketplace make contact
with people try to get some money bury
it in a real estate deal and cross my
fingers and hope that 10 years from now
the rents go up on that building what do
you think the best skills are for a
20-year-old to learn today confidence
you got to have confidence man you got
to have Target attainment you know you
got to know hey this is my target I'm
gonna get it I'm not going home until I
get my damn Target so you guys got to be
you gota you got to get like that drug
addict they don't come home without that
drug no money no credit everybody hates
their guts skanky 74 lbs needle tracks
and the guy still scores a bag clip that
many people listening that don't know
your background you know grew up in Lake
Charles right I think you were one one
of five children uh you know you
certainly didn't come from wealth 100%
like definitely we we I mean we weren't
poor we weren't poverty right I'm not
complaining about my the way I was
brought up because there's a billion
people that came up way worse than I did
we had food I had love I had hugs I had
safety I had dire I had schools I had a
bike uh my mom drove me to I could
either get on the bus or she drive me
nobody was whipping me or beating me or
you know there was not bad stuff
happening
and I blew all
that so I had less money when I was 25
than when I was 15 how's that
possible so uh ended up with a drug
problem bad drug problem between 15 and
25 that I'm not proud of and that I that
I finally beat U that could have killed
me by the way could have just as easily
beat me and uh from the age of 25 till
today I'm still I'm just grinding out
trying to figure out every day doing
something new man like I don't have it
figured out I know I don't have it
figured out but but I'm in a pretty good
place to like okay I know some things
that that are
working and you know back to the 10x
rule I double down on that stuff now I
go hard really hard on a handful of
things rather than try to be great at a
100 things managing money is a is a is
is impossible if you don't increase your
income how can we increase the income
like first you you make it you you
people need to be educated that the most
important thing is to increase income
okay not manage money see this is all
people being told they're say reduce
your expenses but if I make this much
money if I have this much money come in
every month whatever whatever that
number is and I can only manage it that
far right let's say it's 2 in or 2
meters whatever right not 2 meters two
what millimeters yeah centimeters what
is it centimeters centimeters I I got
two centimeters of money right so I have
two centimeters of money we'll take them
the number out of it and I want to
manage this this is what most people are
talk just manage how much how little you
spent but what you should be doing is
figuring out how to increase the income
mhm to 3
cm but but we're not taught that we're
taught how to manage down rather than
increase up so the first thing people
need to be like people just need to be
retaught you need to increase your
income how do I do that first you make a
decision to increase your income that
that is senior to reducing your expenses
my mom thought she was going to reduce
our expenses sold the house okay that's
a less of a burden you can't go up by
going down how do you see AI impacting
the sales career for an individual hey
good man you know let it give you some
ideas you know let let let AI let you
cheat cheat cheat the cheat the pitch
you know uh if if you're calling on a
com somebody in the furniture business
[__] go to Ai and say hey you know
what are CEO is most worried about with
write a short article about what CEOs
are most worried about with uh with
Furniture I I don't know anything about
furniture I I can't know everything
about everything but just give me a
couple things to talk about so I have
some confidence going in you said hey
what is a 20-year-old me confidence
AI cannot give you guys AI cannot be
your confidence Builder okay it could it
can it can it can it could be it could
give you a little
juice but sooner or later you got to
learn your own pitch stand on your own
feet make your own presentation AI is
not going to do that if it does for you
good if you can figure out how to do
that and and and produce another $10
million a month for me come over to my
place I'll give you 10% of it you'll
make 12 million bucks next year let's
roll I want to start for my own business
yeah so like what do you want to do I
mean you got to tell me what what is it
you want to do I want to have a billion
dollar Empire okay so who who's done
that who do you know like you want like
that person did it because it's got it
had to be done once
right uh you okay so how did I do it
though I started I started I've had jobs
I never wanted you know I would get
really really good at that to the point
where people are like man what are you
doing doing what are you on uh why do
you act so good you people should start
trying to hire you guys if you're trying
to make a move out rather than moving to
another company I don't know anything
about your company or whether it's a
good company or there's bonuses
opportunities I would look for a company
or a vehicle I I call company's vehicle
where where the owner of the company was
looking for great people and figure out
how you can deliver greatness to them
and they want to reward you for
that okay so so I would not for
everybody that's listening right now
that might be in her situation I would
not go out and try to start my own deal
right now I would go out and find
somebody that's got a Deal started if
you watch me an undercover billionaire I
didn't go try to start my own company I
found another guy that already had money
that already had credit facilities he
was already in play he was a good guy
and then then I basically went in to
make his company better and I asked for
a piece of the a piece of the uh
action cuz you can't get in my room and
New York so you're going to have to
leave New York seven times what what is
your first name again is it Samantha
Samantha yes seven times I have moved
seeking opportunities I left H I left
Lake Charles I left Houston I left San
Diego I left Los Angeles uh and and I
made two other Moves In order to get
where I'm at today I might make another
move so physically move my location in
order to get what I wanted and for
everybody here look if you want to go to
the next place there's one thing you
will always have to do okay you want to
write this down if you want to get to
the next place you want to go from a
million to 10 million zero to a million
wherever you want to go there will be
one thing that I've always had to do if
I want to improve my life number one you
will always be required to give
something up I don't solve people's
problems I I don't want to solve their
problems you don't borrow money I create
an opportunity I don't lend them money I
create an opportunity I create an
opportunity because look if I lend a guy
money that's got money problems we had a
guy looking at coming to work for us
and he made he made a suggestion that he
needed
X for the job and then he wanted X lent
to him in
advance and I'm like Jared you should go
back to him and say that you're not
going to even present that to me because
it would indicate that he's got money
problems and at this point in his life
he shouldn't have those and and and you
Pro you probably don't want to to to
represent yourself in that fashion so
Jared went back to him and said you know
that's a really bad idea to even tell
Grant you want that and the guy's like
yeah you're probably right don't do that
so we don't want to solve people's
problems we we want to find the right
people we recruit a lot of people if you
are committed to Greatness and you
collaborate with other people and and
lift them up like make other people
great you know my sister said to me when
we were doing this conference it was 4
days she's like my God you shared you
this the the amount of time you give
other people on the stage is
unbelievable right we did a 4-day event
9,000 plus people that was incredible
and you know I give speakers that why
why Grant why you could be up there the
whole time I said no I'm sharing I'm
sharing that platform right right now
what does that do for me first of all it
edifies me for sure it's like 100% I I
don't need to be on the stage they're on
the stage on my behalf M um it it gives
me a network a built-in Network so we
spent $4 million with the manderlay bay
yeah so to to to give me instant okay I
got I got speakers that came from around
the world to deliver
content um I didn't pay them I spent I
wrote a check to Mandalay Bay for 4
million bucks I gave them an audience
they can't most people cannot put 9,000
people in front of themselves so I did
that for a whole bunch of people and
gave them a great qualified audience so
you want to do whatever you have to do
to do what you're saying which is build
this network like to reach up and and I
I realized one day I was watching CNBC
one morning and I saw all the players on
the planet the top 50 or 100 players or
whatever that number is they were all um
showing up in Davos in Switzerland okay
Buffet MH Gates all the players the the
Google boys I'm like dude this look what
are you doing grant what are you doing
man you're so stupid dude you need to go
to Davos you need to show up where the
other players are you need to go there
and eat dinner eat dinner with the Kings
and the queens now I know some people
this goes back to this last thing you
said about the the the morality thing
yeah I don't need all that okay when you
say you don't eat all that you're being
selfish you need to eat with kings and
queens and Power Players because it's
going to accelerate everything for your
family right like if you're one of those
people that want you're a green peace
guy the best thing you could do is go
eat dinner with Bill
Gates Right rather than being in your
little freaking Zodiac boat just just
just doing this Zodiac boat thing
attacking the big ship you need money
you need funding you need support you
need people behind you you can't do
anything by yourself yeah and how and
how so what's the best way that you
found to get into those networks of
people like what is it flow flow Power
Man flow power to people when I moved to
Miami I called a couple people business
owners here in town and I said look
what's your favorite charity I want to
help
out help out flow power to power give
give give don't try to get something
don't try to get on my stage you know I
have have people every day like hey I
want to do business with you I got this
great idea I'm going to make you a
million dollars dude dude dude just flow
power to me yeah right flow power to
power and and keep flowing power to
power right get used to flowing power in
the direction of power I don't end up
doing things that are destructive when
I'm busy doing things that are
constructive the truth is I was never a
drug addict I just had too much free
time and made bad choices this planet is
filled with bad choices pornography
strip joints casinos if you were filled
up all day long with activities if you
were addicted to productivity if you
were junked out on
potential you wouldn't have time for all
the other garbage I would I wouldn't be
I wouldn't spend money on stuff I don't
need when is that money spent when do we
waste most of our money on this planet
during the holidays when we have free
time when do you spend your money when
do you go in debt on the holidays free
time so if I can just stay busy if I can
use time and create time how do I create
time I have 24 hours and I'm like I'm
going to jam as much in those 24 hours
as I can and then I'll let you worry
about me burning out cuz that's what
I'll hear next what about burnout when
you you're going to burn out look I'm 60
years old the more I do the more I can
do and the younger I get the more I do
the younger I feel the more I do the
younger my body feels I'm not going to
burn out I'm not a candle I'm Not wax
the the the counselor back in in in uh
in uh the the the treatment center said
to me dude aren't you worried about cuz
he he's seen my success now and he's
like aren't you worried about burning
out I'm like dude you're the burnout bro
you're the burnout you're the one that
said I was going to come back you're the
one that said I would never make it
you're the one that said uh uh don't
write books I've written seven of them
man okay you're the one that said don't
be a star I am I have my own TV studio
right you're the one that said Grant
don't get rich just be satisfied that
you don't use drugs again no no I got
rich okay I did the rich I did the books
I did the TV I'm going to be on a
billboard I'm going to be on a bus bro
look look what are you doing I'm not
worried about burnout I am not a candle
candles burnout Spiritual Beings don't
how long did it take for you to find
someone that had the same point of view
on obsession with success as you did
because it seems like all the authority
figures in your life were just like okay
with with like where they were or what
they were doing the environment I was in
the automotive environment was filled
with just a lot of very average people
that were satisfied with just having fun
on the weekends like if you could just
Kenny I remember Kenny if Kenny could
just get drunk on the weekend he was
fine just make your 70 grand a year 60
Grand a year if Jose could keep making
his 50 60 70 grand and there he's the
top salesman in the store he'd been
there 15 years or something and he could
get his award he was happy now prior to
that though I had always been looking
for a mentor I had always been searching
so when my dad died my that guy that I
looked up to I started looking for other
guys like that right so TV is available
right there's a lot of mentorship going
on in TV okay I'm start I start watching
all the gangster movies oh wow there's
power right there's success he gets the
girl I watch the James Bond movies so
I'm starting to pull in these ideas of
Role Models or success or what I'm going
to be because I'm trying to formulate my
life it doesn't matter what if you're 10
12 15 18 you don't have a choice you're
making you're trying to become someone
who you are right so I'm pulling in all
this data half of which is like bad
stuff criminals right I forget that they
die at the end of story you know exct um
so those are starting to become our role
models and then when you get into the
educational system school's high school
and college dude it's boring MH the
teachers are boring right like I don't
want to be that guy mhm and and so I'm
searching for who can I be you know and
there's not a lot of uh years ago
there's not a lot of Role Models out
there you've built a massive personal
brand for yourself and for anyone out
there who is aspiring to do that to
where they can leverage that in their
respective industry and the business
world what would you tell them to build
a brand yes build a brand you're
building one anyway look I've always
been a I've always been a person that
people either liked or didn't like but
they knew me I don't really care what
you call me as long as you call me like
I might not be the best player but I'm
going to be out there I'm going to make
some noise I'm going to make some noise
I'm going to figure it out I'm going to
get ridiculed for it too but I'm going
to make some
noise and if you keep getting out there
making noise you're going to figure out
okay you know in the beginning you're
going to be awkward and you're going to
be an idiot and you're going to be made
fun of so the the first thing the only
thing I can do is like the guy shows up
every
day uh last thing I'll tell you I
remember I was growing I was in high
school and I'd go to this place called
The Hungry night I was still bored I was
lost in my life and there was this guy I
don't remember remember his name right
now but every Friday this guy would get
in a
fight not every other Friday bro every
Friday night this guy about 10:30 at
night would go out in the back and throw
down with people and never
won Okay and like God damn and he get up
and he get up he get beat up down and
then he go back in the hungry night and
get drunk again next Friday Bank same
thing third Friday same thing okay after
a while people quit fighting that guy
they're like hey that guy and he never
won the fights by the way and he he
ended up being the the most dangerous
man on those weekends because they're
like he's going to fight no matter what
and I learned from that I watch that I'm
like okay I don't want to fight because
I don't want people hitting on me but
I'm going to keep showing up and no
matter whether they say good things
about me or bad things about me whether
I'm good at what I do or not good I'm
going to keep showing up until people
say guy going to keep showing up bro
just step aside leave him alone the idea
that you have to go to some five year
degree or get a doctorate or whatever I
mean the the most intelligent people on
this planet now are starting to be
challenged for their ideas I would not
go to college okay I would not have
three months of savings ever I would be
broke all the time not broke because I
bought something broke because I
invested I would stay broke because of
my investments my investments I would
live off of cash flow not cash cash flow
cash coming in so if I earn $110,000 or
$3,000 or whatever extra money whatever
the number is 1 billion I would take the
entire amount of money I'd go buy an
asset that pays me cash flow and I would
always live off the cash flow not the
cash I would never spend my earned
income I would only spend income for my
investments that would be a game Cher
for everybody watching for you because
you're the only one you care you care
about that by itself would be a game
changer I would not spend any of my
money and I would not save any money I
wouldn't save money I would not have
three months or 6 months of savings like
a lot of people suggest the Rainy uh
save for a rainy day you know the three
Monon 3mon emergency account I would go
out make money pay my
bills always stay current on my bills I
would never use a credit card to buy
anything if I can't pay for it I
wouldn't do it that's another mistake
you guys are making that I I did not
have the problem with I've never bought
anything I couldn't pay for but I took
the money instead and I saved it in an
account which is just kind of a reverse
way of spending the money cuz it's just
sitting there you're just wasting it
anyway so don't let it just sit anywhere
and don't go buy junk okay what you do
is you take the extra money and you will
park it into an investment like a piece
of real estate there would cash flow for
you and provide you with money next
month that word disruptive what does it
mean to
you it means you know we live on a
planet that is disruptive like like the
whole disruptive thing is like people
like attempting to be disruptive it's
happening whether you want it to or not
like we're in disruption so the the
whole planet you're in disruption you're
in transition this is happening you know
there's the life cycle disruption is
about a cycle and products like people
have cycles of life and if it's not
changing and altering and and if you're
not growing and having fun doing that in
the disruption like if you're surprised
by
disruption then you're not really very
aware like to you'd want to be a little
more aware because it's happening
everywhere retail retail is going to go
through
massive this whole like you got to
wonder what's going to happen
M it's going to be it's going to be mind
boggling the next six or eight 10 years
are going to be probably the most
disruptive we've had economically on
this planet I believe that your full
potential is not revealed to you until
you freaking sharpen the sword till
you're out there in battle and you go
fix it and you you back up and you have
a loss or two and you're like I got to
win like my full potential is being
realized right now you find your
potential by getting up every day
pushing shoving okay challenging the St
status quo many of you are held back
simply because you believe something to
be true you know it to be true truth is
it ain't true you're the only one that
doesn't know it's not true and there's a
lot of those things in life that people
can't find their potential because
they're so stuck in being right so this
is my question back to you and you have
a great question are you fortunate
because you're able or are you able
because you're fortunate there's a big
difference some people are just able
because they got the money and the
resources they were born rich but some
people some people find their fortunes
because they're able I'm able and I
increased my abilities and I got better
and better and because of that I became
more fortunate it's like the old adage
the harder I work the luckier I am
you've sold billions of dollars in
Revenue throughout your career you know
how have you been able to consistently
close massive deals what is Grant
Cardone secret to sales 80% of
everything we do here is free now the
20% that pay me you know this year will
pay me $150 million but the 80% got got
a billion dollars worth of advice they
just didn't pay me anything but they
came into my funnel right they came into
my okay now I know who they are can I
serve them when they're ready to pay
something not everybody's ready to pay
right so like when I was a kid man I I
wouldn't pay for anything I didn't have
any
money so if if I went you know if you
walk into a casino in Vegas you can walk
in you don't have to have money all you
got to do is walk in everything's free
so in my world I'm a big open Casino
like everything's free now when you get
in you're like you know I'd like to sit
at that table with the whales well then
that cost something or I want to sit
over this table with the $100 players or
I want to go over here and play this
game well to do that then you got to sit
down and you got to pay so we've raised
$1.1 billion crowdfunding on the
internet I don't go to wealthy people I
don't go to Mark Cuban and say hey fund
my project I I've never gone to a big um
Equity Fund like a Blackstone and say
give me a mill billion dollars I could
but I don't I go to I build a big
audience I create great products and
offers and then I go to that audience
and say would you guys like to invest
with me so out of we I think we have
450,000 people in an investor uh that
raised their hand and said I'm
interested in your Investments 13,000 of
the 400,000 invested with me you need to
change your mind about closing people
closing people is when you service them
for the first time you guys need to
understand that when you close a deal
when somebody actually buys your product
service offer whatever your offer is
that's when you finally serve
I don't think about the clothes being I
got you I got you you know I don't think
about it being that and I think a lot of
salesp people think oh I got you you
know no I didn't get you dude I finally
I finally serviced you when I closed you
by the way that should be the first
close that should be of the 154,000
people that bought something for me last
year 45,000 of them have bought 3 four 5
6 seven eight things like 30% of our and
and I want to get the other 70% to to
make sure that's not the first thing and
the only thing they bought from you if
you're just tuning in right now you you
need you need one tip on how to network
better how to increase your inner circle
what is that make a list make a list man
who do you want to network with it's
like getting a job you know the way the
way the way colleges are taught how to
get a job is you look for the industry
that's expanding that's completely
ridiculous you work for people not
companies yeah so you want to make
that's so true that's something if I
could go back that I would that would
change that so dumb dude what industry
do you want to work in well I'm in a
accountant so who's hiring accountants
oh the gas industry is hiring
accountants you're not going to work for
the gas industry and you're not going to
work for a company you're going to work
for a person so what people you talk
about acceleration man don't go get a
job go work for a person yeah right so I
would make a list who do I want to
network with who do I want to eat dinner
with who who do I want to spend time
with right not mentoring I'm not talking
about mentoring you guys me Mentor you
need to read a book right I don't like
the mentoring thing is so
overblown I I've never called somebody
and said will you please be my mentor
not in a formal way no no what I'll do
is I'll I'll grab a guy that's written
this much this many books and I'm like
that's my mentoring I'm going to read
everything that guy put together yeah
I'm going to study every audio program
he has I'm going to study everything
he's done that's how you get mentoring
so the network thing is about how do you
hook up with players man go get you some
Equity you know Jay-Z talks about this
you're getting you know so many you
young brothers are getting in advance
while I'm picking up the equity ooh yeah
they're trying to get the to get rich
quick let me give you the money now now
where the Publishers getting the
long-term residual income for decades
off of Kevin har look at what Kevin Hart
did with this with this show right he
owns that show he owns the ticket sales
he was willing to promote it not just be
a comedian where Richard Pry showed up
and got his check told his jokes Uh
Kevin Hart says yeah I'm going show up
I'm going to tell my jokes but I'm going
to own I'm going to own the entire
platform the equity so how do you get
someone to give you $10,000 when you
have nothing to give them in return or
what is it that you're selling them uh a
greater promise in return so what I did
was I pitched this guy I said look he's
a business owner he wants traffic in his
company every every business owner wants
traffic every entrepreneur wants traffic
to their website and I said look I'm
going to drive traffic to your store he
owned a mattress store big margins and I
said I'm going to I'm going to make sure
you have the biggest weekend that you've
ever been here and uh I said if you give
me $6,000 I'll take the six grand to the
store in fact you don't give me the
money just call it in and approve it I
didn't want to touch his money I never
asked anybody for any money and I said
I'm going to go run a promotion for you
I'm going to put together the banners
the logos I'm going to stand out in the
street I'm going to drive the traffic to
your place what do you want Grant oh
Lewis what do you want Lewis uh I did
that more than once by the way what do
you want leis you did cuz my name was
Lewis right yeah yeah yeah and I said
dude I don't want anything he tried to
give me money to do this I don't want
your money I just want the opportunity I
want to prove
myself cuz what I really wanted from him
was I wanted him to front the bill at
The Print Shop so that he could put me
and play well I went and ran the whole
promotion that weekend I said if you if
you send them if you just are authorize
the spend I'll conduct a promo I'll run
it and do
it we did
$91,000 wor the mattress sales we did
15,000 that weekend and then another
65,000 over the the next 3
weeks and he's like dude you're a
star now now he's like hey what do you
want for what you did for me this
weekend that was the best weekend we've
ever had and I'm like I don't want
anything except to be your partner so so
you want to Equity I want to be your
partner dude and I said I want 15% of
the upside of your company I said what's
fair he's like 15% everything above what
I'm doing now I'll give you 15% he he's
the one that made the offer I said
that's awesome and then that's when I
said hey can you give me an advance of
10,000 on the 15% people think that I
asked for 10 grand I actually didn't get
10,000 I got an advance on a partnership
which is even better wow you're never
satisfied you're always looking for
something to to get out of bed for right
like to be
so I had one more building okay I had
one what what am I doing and why am I
doing it so she says let's just play a
game okay she says what if you 10x the
income of the company
now and I said okay then we go from 150
million a year in the internet sales and
340 in real estate income to what would
that be 500 five billion a year right
that's a big deal I'm like man five
billion a year I don't need all that
money the first thing I did was I do
exactly what everybody else does you
know you stretch the rubber band and
wants to go back to its old size right
yep I'm like what do I need five billion
dollar for I don't need five billion now
I got to pay three billion in taxes I
only got two billion left over what am I
gonna do with2 billion I don't need that
she's like play the game Grant play the
game you know and I'm literally like ah
you know why I do it you know but then
when I start playing it I'm like okay
what would I do you you know I would
definitely buy a yacht I'd buy a $300
million
yacht uh i' I'd waste 30 million a year
on it I'd go buy a big
Ranch that I go to once or twice a year
and then I start thinking about okay
what would I do with this thing and I
would expand I would take a bunch of
money and expand I probably take some
risk on some AI technology stuff to add
to our 10x health system and see if we
could scale that worldwide you know
so it typ typically what happens for me
is in that doing that exercise it just
kind of resonates with me for and starts
to kind of work itself because I'm still
thinking about it five hours later now
figure out the problems you're having
which is needs to be another list right
here your story comes from your
problems okay so look let's just take
this who am I oh I'm Grant Cardell okay
that's my name well you can only no okay
Grant on okay now later what happened
because I started telling my story
enough I became somebody other than
Grant Cardone okay over the last 12
years it's only been 12 years since I
started on the
multimedia did I say the multimedia see
okay that I became Mr
10x and that I became Uncle
G and then I became Master
G these are nicknames that people gave
me okay okay these are stories that you
get to tell how did I become Uncle G
because one day I told a story about how
I was 15 and 16 and 17 years old and I
wanted an uncle to help me and they
never came and that I told my mom one
day I'm going to be an uncle to
others I'm gonna be the uncle to others
that my uncle wasn't to me and somebody
started calling me Uncle G right see
again it comes out of stories who are
you who are you okay I'm going to give
you this a assment to sit down and start
looking at who are you oh I'm a college
grad I graduated from
college okay who else oh I'm a
father so what I want you to do is
everything I'm a father I'm a
husband okay this list is going to get
real big I'm a business
owner anything to do with business owner
oh I survived 2008 huge part of my Story
by the way I saw I resol 2008 with no
bankruptcy all my friends went bankrupt
that's part of my story this is going to
be the content oh I'm a real estate
investor
cdy okay now I'm a cat daddy which by
the way I'm not proud
of I'd much rather be Tiger King okay
okay so I'm a real estate investor all
right oh I have $1.8 billion do wor a
real estate a lot of you out there
you're like oh he's always bragging he's
always bragging look if you're not
telling your story if you're not
bragging about your story you're not
telling your
story Jay-Z is going to tell people
until people finally say it about him
that he's the
Jay-Z okay one day you're going to be
able to walk in a room and you will not
have to introduce yourself the whole
room will get sucked out the the the
energy in the room will get sucked out
because everybody will do this oh he's
here look who's here that's what this is
about it's about marketing yourself
until the world knows you to the point
you don't have to introduce yourself
when I went to high school and in
business classes my first business
classes is and then went on uh in
college to spent five years in college
studying accounting and getting a a
master's in
business not a master's in business I
didn't get a master's in business I got
a business
degree I was a master of
nothing I remember getting out of
college with an accounting degree and
could not balance a checkbook didn't
know the difference between an asset and
a liability didn't know how to run a
profit and loss statement didn't know
how to control the top one inch of a
profit and loss statement and if You' to
ask me what was more important the most
important part of a profit and loss
statement I would have known what to
tell you I knew nothing but I did know
one thing I wanted to learn about
money and because I was so scared about
money because of the way I was brought
up the mentality around my house was
because we didn't know how to get new
money we had to save save the money that
we had save for a rainy day you know a
penny a penny saved is a penny earned
and uh money doesn't grow on trees but I
didn't know where it grew I didn't know
how it was manufactured how it was
created how could I get some why would I
save it how do I earn it how long does
it take to multiply knew I knew nothing
about money and so for the past 25 years
maybe 30 years now I've been studying
money how do I get it how do I keep it
now what do I do with it I was 33 years
old when a man told me he said to me hey
Grant you know how to make money now
you've learned how to make money you're
putting money together your business is
working now you have to learn how to get
money to make money and that's the first
time I'd ever heard that how do I get
money to make money and I went out and
started reading books on money I read a
book about other people's money I read
uh books about how Banks make money I
read books about how people made money I
read about the Rockefellers and the
margin and the Vanderbilts and all these
people that had created these massive
massive
wealthspring billionaires and the
Jay-Z's and today like today we look
around like people are being made into
billionaires Mark Zuckerberg at 26 years
old is a
billionaire like none of this was
available when I was growing up now now
the
potential the
possibility for somebody to be extremely
wealthy I think last week uh last week
Elon Musk Network went up 8
billion we have two pre two guys running
for
president um Donald
Trump a
billionaire Michael Bloomberg is worth
69 billion dollar he could burn he could
burn Donald Trump's money up he probably
will by the way he'll burn Donald
Trump's net worth running for the
presidential office spent $300
million in the first three
weeks of his run for presidency he spent
more money Mike Bloomberg has spent more
money than all the Democrats combined
and Donald Trump's campaign to
date in 3 weeks freaking unbelievable
and it moved him from zero points in the
polls to 15 points as of this morning
money Works folks okay and what you
don't know about it will work against
you and what you do know about it can
work against you and I know it worked
against me I didn't have money I spent
the First Once I learned how to make
money I I I I literally did not know
what to do with it so I started
collecting data about money and I
started learning from the places where I
was comfortable which is your
surroundings ing your environment and in
my surroundings you know I was told
don't waste money don't play with money
save money put money in the bank get
some money bring it to the bank get some
money bring it to the bank get some
money bring it to the bank go out and
work get some money bring it to the bank
and that's what I kept doing I'm like
wait a minute dude I'm I'm feeding the
bank and I was reading this book one day
and learned that when I give the money
to the bank when I take the money and
put it in the
bank they take the money convert it to
digit
I did not know this and then they pushed
it out into the system and lent it nine
and 10 times I was like whoa they don't
even keep the money I give them big
shout out to all the haters and the
criticizers the rumor mongers the the
gossipers the people out there that are
that you hear on the clubhouse or
Instagram or Facebook hating on people
criticizing people making people wrong
bullying them just remember this when
you hear that when you hear somebody
hating on somebody else in my 63 years
of being on this planet I have never in
my life had somebody hate on me and I've
had a lot of people hate on me criticize
me try to shame me pick out all my damn
Character defects look at all the iron
in here okay they got something really
special back here though I have never
ever
never ever had somebody hate on my game
that accomplished more than I had not
one damn time in my life Elon those guys
over at the top of the food chain
they're not talking about me they're not
threatened by me now I've had some
people unable to accomplish what I've
accomplished spend all their damn time
talking sh about me
you know the crazy thing is when you're
talking about somebody that's above you
that's accomplished more than you try
throwing up at people above you it
always going to fall on your face
everybody listening to it saying okay
yeah oh that's funny that's funny that's
funny and then they going to be like why
is he talking so much about this
gu you
can't about you it's going to fall all
over your face your forehead your
reputation so look for all of you out
there just remember when you're hearing
somebody hate on somebody else that
person I guarantee you there you'll
never find there to be an exception to
this rule the person they're hating on
has accomplished more than they have and
the person that's doing a hating has
accomplished not nearly as much just a
damn fact man look Envy really Envy is
the core the core the root of hate Envy
jealousy
insecurities
scarcity
trying to trying to tear somebody else
down to build themselves up and it never
works you just can't do that you can't
get up tearing other people down all you
end up is down it's like the old crab
syndrome in the bucket they just pulling
each other down trying to get up and
they just keep pulling each other down
so remember when you hear somebody
hating on whatever a person a company
religion Family Fun a movie
when you are being
bullied
or somebody's attempting to bully you
tear you down ruin your reputation you
are talking to somebody that is filled
with jealousy and envy and insecurities
and scarcity complexes and
narcissism
and when they're hating they're not
creating when they're not creating they
cannot do better in life it's impossible
it's like a disease from the inside so
just remember that when you're hearing
that you might want to separate yourself
from those that are doing that you
definitely don't want to be that because
those that do that don't do much else
all you have to do is go out and be
willing to go talk to people and if you
go talk to enough of the right people
then you will find the right person and
and literally that this was so funny
because he uh was telling me after he
got back he's like literally within the
first uh 48 hours I had met the two
people that were were going to make
everything that happened on that show
possible I knew I knew I knew it wasn't
it wasn't a week it wasn't it wasn't a
month it was literally The First 48
hours all I did for the first 10 days is
meet people mhm okay but you got to meet
the right people okay who are the right
people you know who are assets and who
are liabilities okay on day one in 19
days in this workbook we're going to
take a list of the people that you know
okay and and the people you don't know
that could actually change the the the
the future of your life okay who could
actually change the future make you the
millionaire the
decamillionaire hecta millionaire the
heca millionaire or the billionaire
because I promise you you ain't getting
there without them and the people that
you
know have you where you
are just so you know like the people
that you know if you're network is your
net
worth then the network you have right
now has something to do with the net
worth that you have right now you guys
got to become a threat to your
environment amen you got to become a
threat to your environment you got to
become such a threat to your environment
people start like your competition
starts talking about you because that's
free
promotion you got to get people to
promote you and you can't nobody's going
to promote somebody not winning you know
they're not going to hate on people
losing they're going to hate on people
that are winning
it just comes with the thing so in in in
that promotion because people don't
remember you remember a Tylenol Tylenol
was taken off the shells 20 years ago
number one bestselling headache
medication in the world today and it was
taken off the
shelves so so you have to figure out how
to get how to do something big enough in
your Marketplace you know the fourth
reason the market is to get a customer
but if you hit the third one you're
going to get the fourth
one so I don't know if I answered your
question but you can't stay you can't
you can't just keep being a 50 car store
right so the 10x concept would be this
like okay we did 50 we're going to
figure out how to do 500 right you don't
go 50 to 55 cuz you're never going to
get to 55 is about you is about your
company it's about your vision it's
about your dream it's not about what you
want to do you have to sell like if you
look at a financial
statement any financial statement
anywhere I go in the world I go to
Singapore I go to Dubai I go to Detroit
I go to California
I'm working with the government I'm
working with the military I'm working
with a tech company a software company a
real estate company every income
statement okay every income statement
the first line on that income statement
the first line in every part of the
world without exception there is no
exception to this rule the top line
is
revenue sales something it's going to
say something about gross sales revenue
it's the Topline of the business man why
do you think it's the Top Line
cuz it's the most important thing and
everybody's like I don't want to do
sales okay all right you you you think I
was talking about having sex with the
devil like dude all you all you're doing
is growing your company there's no way
to get away from this this is not a job
this is a
business and that's why the number one
most important thing in our company is
that line right there they are the most
protected group of people in the
company like there's nobody more
protected in my companies than the
salespeople in our real estate the
leasing agent the leasing agent gets a
client comes in drives across town once
to look at our apartment we should close
that deal they didn't come to my
apartment building to say no they came
to my apartment building to find a place
to live when we're trying to fill a
stadium with 34,000 people that's one
sale at a time there's no trick to this
Warren Buffett recently said the reason
they don't buy real estate is because
real estate for most most of the the of
time for hundreds of years in America
real estate is properly valued and he
looks for assets that are not properly
valued stressed or something they're
stressed they're a problematic and he
says the reason real estate they have
not been able to accumulate real estate
uh at birkshire is because there's only
one thing that causes real estate to be
incorrectly valuated or valued and that
one thing is financial problems crisis a
crisis a debt crisis or banking crisis
it happened in 1996 that's when I
started buying real estate it happened
again in 2008 I bought a bunch of real
estate and it's going to happen right
now so we have a correction that is
completely underway and it's happening
right now two the second reason you want
to be in real estate is because it's
time tested okay it's been around for
thousands and thousands of years real
estate is is valuable or more valuable
than gold the reason I like real estate
more than gold or silver or hard
products or Commodities is because it it
provides me with cash flow not just a a
a real product okay three it builds net
worth uh you know this about your home
your personal home can build net worth
okay your your parents bought a house
for
$28,000 30 years ago house is worth 4500
Grand a day and it's paid for that
Bill's net worth number four major
reason major reason that you want to do
this is the tax benefits okay most of
you don't understand the tax benefits
taxes represent 40% of all your expenses
at least some of you guys that live in
Connecticut New York New Jersey Illinois
California dude your your tax bills in
the 60% you don't even know it unemploy
employment taxes Social Security
benefits uh property taxes sales taxes
car taxes
um God dang tax okay number five passive
income okay passive income now Bitcoin
does not offer passive income stocks do
not offer passive income uh 5year
treasury bills don't offer passive
income cash at the bank doesn't offer
passive income work does not offer a
passive income you need passive income
Warren Buffett said if you don't learn
how to make money while you sleep you
will spend your entire life working for
money you can't keep did y'all know the
whole the whole saying right there
that's what it is number six okay number
six inflation
hedge and we are about to go through
some people believe that we're going to
go into hyperinflation in this country
because we keep printing money it's
probably it's probably 5 to 10 years
from now but if we go into
hyperinflation if you've ever lived in
countries like Venezuela Argentina uh go
to Greece look at what happened in
Greece 15 years ago Dude they were
literally burning their money in the
streets okay they were literally using
it for firewood here we are
2023 a home is 400 Grand it's gone up 15
times and interest rates doubled in the
last couple years so the same you know
interest rates were 18% back then it but
it was still a lower payment than on on
$25,000 than it would be today uh and a
lot of people are like I don't want to
own a home today it's not a great
investment but there's going to be so
many opportunities here real estate
there's a couple of vectors that are
going to offer phenomenal phenomenal
opportunities you mentioned some of the
stocks the the the most efficient stocks
companies in the world the apples the
Facebook books that I don't know about
the Netflix because they're going to get
pounded here but that's tough coca-colas
the McDonald's these are companies that
deliver real products and real and maybe
don't even have to go outside the
country to get them like Dunkin Donuts
you know there's no there's no supply
issues there they they cook their duts
in the morning and Brew their coffee and
sell it and make a margin real estate is
going to be tremendous opportunity
single family homes and Commercial Real
Estate like I buy tremendous phenomenal
um Decades of opportunities like
literally I I'll probably buy more real
estate this year than I bought in the
previous decade and I bought a lot of
real estate and then small businesses
there's 32 million small businesses that
I mentioned earlier uh about 18 million
of them Break Even or lose money those
people that own those businesses are
tired they went through covid now
they're going through inflation they're
exhausted they're they're over 50 years
old some of them over 70 years old and
they're like I'm tapping out I think
it's it'll be easier this year to buy 10
businesses with no money for your
audience that doesn't have any money you
could literally buy 10 businesses today
cheaper than you could start your own
business and probably ex scale 10 times
faster than grow your own business 10%
what's your thoughts and feelings around
what is happening and what you think
will happen over the next 12 to 18
months so I'm going to say something
that I think most people would disagree
with me on but first of all inflation is
is a boogeyman that's not even real
really look I'm just telling you
inflation even warm Buffet says maybe
two people on the entire planet even
understand the concept of inflation
complic what is inflation so inflation
yeah it's a great question right and
what is the recession by the way yeah so
uh inflation is uh an increased price or
price on some commodity that is desired
right so you actually want inflation you
don't not want inflation why because you
want your you want your the value of
your products to go up not down if
you're thinking as a consumer okay which
you're not dreaming big if you're
thinking as a consumer oh my God bananas
went up okay don't eat them uh eggs went
up eggs did not go up because of of the
the this
Boogeyman okay and it didn't go up
because the dollar went down in value so
if and it didn't go up because we print
money it's none of this is true now I
know your audience in the comments
they're going to freaking try to destroy
me so if we print a bunch of money if
you print a trillion dollars okay and
put it in this building right
now nothing inflated you just print a
bunch of money it is the distribution of
that
money okay a distribute the money to to
a billion
people then they have money okay that
even the distribution of the money
sharing a trillion dollars would not in
create inflation it is when in it is
when the money is moved into the
marketplace that's when inflation
happens I if the consumer the dreamer
the person elects to use the money okay
so inflation was created because we gave
everybody a $1,400 check and people went
and bought they didn't need and couldn't
afford by the way inflation is created
by me buying eggs that are too expensive
that I can't afford so if the eggs are
too expensive don't buy them the
marketplace will take care of it then
it'll go back down eventually exactly
Okay so your supplies will go up and
people will be like I got all these eggs
I want to get rid of them so let's I'll
do two for one or three for one or four
for one the inflation was caused by the
supply chains blocked up because of
covid and because things weren't getting
shipped around the country it was not
caused because inflation is not caused
because of printing money even though
that's what most people
believe causes inflation if I print a
trillion dollars and leave it in this
room it would be fill up more than this
room but if I printed a trillion dollars
or 4 trillion or 6 trillion whatever
they just just did and leave it in this
room there's no inflation it's a
non-event so this idea that printing
money incre uh creates inflation is not
the truth now if I distribute $6
trillion to every household in America I
still have not actually caused inflation
okay because it hasn't been used it's
not in the system yet you get a bunch of
money she gets a bunch of money my gets
a bunch of money I get a bunch of money
un until we move the money into the
marketplace now if all these people went
out and bought assets real assets yeah
of course every I'm we're all able to
pay more money because we have more
money so if just if your audience can
just follow the thinking here and I'm
just asking people to think think with
this this is what I'm thinking with the
reason we have inflation is because
people were sent $1,400 check some of
your audience is not going to like what
I'm about to say say it you guys were
sent a $1,400 check check you got a
$1,400 check and you went and spent
money that you shouldn't have spent on
you didn't need that is the new
definition of inflation people that get
money and then spend it on stuff they
don't need don't really don't don't not
required living and you probably
couldn't afford and wouldn't have done
it had you not gotten that check now
people like me I I didn't I didn't cause
inflation you caused inflation I went
and took my money and invested it I
buried it in projects in real assets and
so every time I got any check over the
last two or three years or for the last
30 years I take all the money I get it's
all garbage money's garbage and I
convert it into buildings I'm walking
through you what what is what is your
assistant's name uh Alex Johnson yeah
you atin bringing me into the building
what was I saying all the way from the
curb oh my God this building I should
buy this building like I just get like
to me buildings are like like they're
like I I can buy this today if I can
hold on for for 10 or 15 or 20 years
what would you say your superpower is I
mean you've done all kinds of things and
you've got an incredible track record
but what would you say like your
superpower is right now as you sit here
today uh man I don't know I think
everybody's got a lot of superpowers so
but what's the dominant one that you
would say Grant Cardone when you look in
the mirror it's like this is what I do
this is my special sauce one is
persistence man I just don't quit like
if I tell you guys I'm gonna buy 100,000
units and I am going to own 100 I'll be
one of the largest apartment owners in
the world I have never ever stopped the
only way to stop me is to kill me and
then I'm not I would even question
whether I come back or not I'm a boom
you know so so persistence I I have
built my persistence muscle up it was
all that cold calling I was doing when I
was 30 uh the second one is I'm
extremely disciplined with money and it
doesn't matter whose it is could be your
money your brother's money it doesn't
matter whose it is I watch money I never
lose it I respect it and I try to
multiply it um and on the same thing on
buying property like I don't use your
money any different than I would my own
money and I'm not
Reckless um because I'm self-made like
I'm I'm I came up from the mud and you
know I'm never had a silver spoon I've
never had anybody give me anything the
fact that I've never taken money for an
institution and and got the size that I
am is like it's really unheard of what
did you do to get from 1 billion to 4.2
in 3 years btim more real estate I mean
that's how you do it you got to buy the
real estate right you got to you know
you got to you got to either raise money
or you got to have money and both of
those are possible so you guys out there
are saying I don't have any money oh my
God if I had money I'd have done that
too no you got to either get money earn
money or you got to raise money one of
the two and it's easier to raise money
if you've already worked and earn money
because then people can trust you that
you know how to trade time for money at
a job
so you know like people trust me they
trust my work eth think people may not
like my energy or they might not like
the way I say something but nobody's
going to say I don't work they're going
to say here guys guy's got track record
35 years showing up doing what he said
he was going to do yeah he's he's cocky
and he's this and he's that and and he
says whatever he wants but look you
probably would too like like yeah but
but I do what I say I'm going to do too
and and and and then I stack real estate
assets we picked up3 billion
almost three billion during the
plandemic and then took a Hiatus we
hadn't bought anything in the last year
and we're I'm about to I'm about to blow
this portfolio up so well next time I'm
on this podcast I'll be at 10 billion
this cycle right now they we're in is
going to be the biggest real estate
opportunity in my lifetime and everybody
is listening like this is it's it's time
to be ready all the time not get ready
cuz it's happening right now what's your
advice to Brokers headed into this
season right cuz most Brokers I know
have had an epic run the last two or
three years epic run made a insane
amount of money right they don't even
know how to dial right exactly they
forgot how the fundamentals right they
forgot they they stopped doing it
because it was so easy they got a
listing and had 20 offers so in this
current season we're going into Brokers
are down 70 80% they're forecasting
being down 70 80% in sales volumes
what's the advice for some of the top
for the Brokers out there you know you
need to go back and
really you know renew those
relationships that maybe you've ignored
a little bit
um I know what we're doing like you know
Brokers are very very valuable to us
like insane never pay too much for a
broker they've never earned too much
money on a deal um Brokers out there
like you got to find out who's buying
I'm I'm on the top I'm on the list now
the problem with the list today is the
other guys on the list are
institutions so you're going to have to
go in the list now and find the
individuals because the individuals are
are going to
rain power for the next 18
months I I got two meetings this week
from the top five groups to go look at
their portfolio to purchase I could not
get that meeting a year ago so I would
tell Brokers you guys need to arrange
that meeting for me individuals
entrepreneurial people with a bunch of
powder I'm sitting on 350 cash right
now 350 big ones okay and I'm raising
money every day and don't mind moving
into this cycle this I was built for
this cycle you got to find more guys
like me that did not depend on Sovereign
funds hedge funds and institutions for
their dough what Roi are you looking
when you're investing okay Roi return on
investment okay are we would call Cash
Flow It's the cash flow that I'm really
looking for okay there's a there's a
couple terms one is uh you could use Roi
cash flow is a term all these are made
up though guys like it's like how good's
the building the better the building is
the better the future that building is
the less I need for return what why
number one reason you want to write this
down number one reason and you need to
know these you need to know this is why
I'm doing
this he he's not sure why he's doing it
cuz right now he's like what's my Roi
okay number one reason it might be
because of your age but number one
reason is
what preserve
Capital why am I buying the real estate
okay why am I buying the real estate I
want to preserve Capital Melissa gave me
a million dollars I'm a consultant I
consult her business she gives me a
million dollars to consult the business
I want to preserve the million dollars
if you keep the million dollars you're
going to lose it you're going to get
taxed out of it it's going to depreciate
everybody agree you want to convert
paper to
buildings okay I like I have a rule I
never convert paper to more
paper I I'd convert it to bitcoin before
I convert it back to dollars or treasury
bills personally I actually believe in
the blockchain more than I believe in
the treasury
Department oh yeah this guy oh here go
the
Maxis Bitcoin people will go crazy now
watch okay how many crypto people in a
room these people are
nuts okay they're like the drug addicts
of the
blockchain okay you start talking to
these people you drop a quarter in them
tell me about crypto
oh these people would talk for 17 days
all right so one you want to protect
your capital okay this is why people get
it now I want to keep it the way to keep
it is to convert it you cannot keep cash
without losing it it's going down in
value in your lifetime it's low 70% of
his value my lifetime has lost 70% of my
value yeah exactly okay one you want to
protect your Capital number one two you
want cash flow these are my criteria for
investing in anything that's why I don't
load up on bitcoin because it doesn't
hit number two it doesn't cash them this
is what you never want to do and I've
said for years never never ever over
leverage your properties these guys were
boring 80 and 85 and 90% sometimes 100%
of the deal they were putting B
basically 20% down that was raiseed
money check out what they were doing
there they got interest rate a floating
interest rate that's now at
72 and they promised their investors
some preferred interest of probably 8 to
12% I don't know exactly what they
offered in this deal but each deal had
to basically make 20% a
year just to break even and they hadn't
even done the rehab yet so they had to
pay back 20% a year plus they had to
spend 15 20 or 20,000 a unit on
thousands of units $20
million on a bad
location okay so they bought sh product
ship location
overleveraged
it and then they had no cash
reserves in case of problems like
there's not going to be problems guys
there's always going to be problems okay
every piece of real estate I've ever
bought every business I've ever
purchased every business that I started
every startup I've got involved in every
relationship partnership every single
deal I have ever bought came with
problems that I did not forecast I did
not manage most of you guys who were
buying real estate in the last three
years you're like oh we're going to have
growth every year we're going to have
rent growth forever everything's going
to go perfect we're going to do our
rehab we're going to keep it full at 95%
why does everybody use this 95% number
not it's impossible not not everybody
can be at 95% okay particularly with
they got new assets coming on these guys
were buying assets in terrible
locations knowing that new product was
coming on in an adjustable rate mortgage
Market where the FED said the interest
rates are are going to be going up we're
under capitalized don't have money for
the future to buy down the loan and
check it out didn't even have any
reserves to fix the property cash is not
King there is a king and it is not cash
cash is garbage okay cash flow now would
be a different
conversation constant cash flow cash
look cash is going down in value in fact
I want to give you something I did a
little study this morning in in
1960 okay this this is a conversation
everybody here if you want to know more
about money you have to figure this out
out okay in
1960 if I had
$1,000 and then I come out to if I come
out to
n28 how much money how many thousands of
dollars do you think I would need in
1960 to buy the same services
today as in 19 1960 I was born in 1958
by the
way 8,000 in 1992 in
1992 this $1,000 and you take it out to
to to 2018 you would need you would need
[Music]
uh
$1,744 to buy the same goods and
services okay this was
8269 so now this is really really
important don't get lost here you're
like what what just happened here okay
I'm going to show you I'm going to give
you a very simple very very simple and
I'm going to explain to you what Warren
Buffett says only a handful of people on
planet Earth understand it's called
inflation there's
$1,000 and I'm just going to pull off
what looks like
eight yeah that's eight I got to add one
it's it's short 100 okay I wonder how
close I am maybe somebody can count this
out okay okay now in 1960 when I was
when I was 2 years old this is what it
took you could go with $1,000 and you'd
buy whatever washing machine dry car
payments house payments blah blah blah
if you wanted to buy those items today
those same items today this is the
understanding of inflation you would
need eight times the money to purchase
the same products okay so what happened
okay ask yourself this question $11,000
in 1960 is worth what today if I had
$1,000 put it in my drawer in 1960 came
back 57 years later 58 years later and
grabbed it how much money would be in
the drawer same ,000 is in there nothing
happened to the ,000 you understand we
still have $11,000 this is this is
inflation simplified this is what they
don't teach you at school right $11,000
in two in
19508 is a
1960 is 1,000
in 2018 the difference is the difference
however is this bought this bought this
product right here okay and by
2018 it didn't buy the same product it
bought
1/8 1/8 of the products okay now what
does that mean to you that means
cash right because what happened to
these products these products went up
price these products went up eight times
while money went down or the that went
up and this stayed the same however you
want to figure it out but cash is not
King folks okay cash is not King in fact
you'd have probably been better off
buying $1,000 worth of real estate back
in
1960 and getting rid of your dough cuz
what do you think that piece of property
would be work today if it was in a
decent location never loan money to
anyone ever listen to me you're not a
bank you're not an ATM you're not a
credit card okay you got a name it ain't
MasterCard it is I need to make money I
need to take care of family I need to
take care of my business I need to get
my wealth right I need to create wealth
and then and not even then would you
ever loan money to anyone especially
friends and family okay do not do it I'm
telling you don't solve their money
problem all they're going to do is suck
you into their money problem so number
four I have never done this I've done
this one time in in in literally 30
years okay and that time I was
disappointed never loan money to anyone
if they can't get it from a bank they
shouldn't be able to get it from you
their money problems will become your
money problems let them go fix those if
they can and then come back and I know
what you're going to tell me you're
going to be like oh Grant man it's all
about the money with you that's why it's
called the non-negotiable money tips
this is about money okay I'm staying
away from people that got money problems
if I'm a real friend of yours and I'm
going through trouble right now why
would I want to bring my trouble to you
stay away from people that have money
problems okay these are my
non-negotiable money tips look I came up
from nothing if you don't know who I am
literally started with nothing 25 years
old I had no money no credit no Finance
no Mentor there was no training or
education about money I knew nothing
about it I just knew one thing I wanted
it and I also knew that I wanted more
than I had and so I started studying and
reading every book I could on finance
all these wealthy people I ran into this
book The Millionaire Next Door I'm going
to save my way to money I'm I'm going to
not drink the coffee and I'm I'm going
to buy the used truck okay it's
ridiculous okay you guys get a million
dollars you know less about money than
people that are broke okay a million
dollars is not enough money for you it's
not enough money for your future it's
not enough money for your security and
it's definitely not enough money for
retirement for a fire to burn
everybody's like who started the fire
dude somebody who kept it going
you know I think the better question is
how do you keep the fire
burning because everybody's got the
spark everybody's got the spark it's
like how'd you put it out how'd you put
it out who put it out how do you find it
again and then once you get it again
thene how do you add wood to it I talked
about this in a book that I wrote called
if you're not first or last build a fire
so hot so big so enormous that people
from all over the world regardless of
who you are your religion your race your
age your sex they're like I gotta go sit
by that damn fire and like you could see
it for Miles Away
um you know so like the fact that you
say I'm a catalyst to other people that
that's so in that is such a store of
wealth for me it's like you just filled
up this big Silo of what should be wheat
in it uh with purpose and um because
that that is the ultimate wealth the
ultimate wealth is I helped other people
you know another another huge Silo of
wealth is my my personal confidence that
I can do I can I the the the idea that I
can do almost
anything and not saying I can do
anything I can't do anything but but but
if I don't quit dude I could probably
figure it out you know and and I have
confidence in myself not to quit today
so and I think the Catalyst that I
become for other people today is not the
Jet and it's not the the the the
money the UL I mean I think some of that
turns a lot of people on and off I think
the real one the one that really
like that inspires my peers is dude your
energy bro is like like you just always
relight when I thought you were bright
you get it brighter when I thought you
were big you make it bigger and and I
don't do that for people I'm not trying
to please other people I'm trying to
please me hey all you guys out there
living the
dream I always hear people say that hey
how you doing man I'm living the dream
that's what people say I'm like really I
don't think so I've never said that I
hate that saying by the way I'm living
the dream but are you really and so
that's what I want to ask you are you
living your dream and what does it me do
you even know have you written it down
where do you want to visit who do you
want to hang
with what do you want to do with your
time you know you have kids you have a
marriage what's life look like you know
for me I really didn't know what it
looked like I just wanted to be better
have some a little more I was telling my
sister the other day she's like do you
ever imagine your life would be this I
said no and that's a regret I have I I
regret that I actually didn't imagine
and didn't have or know what was
possible and I think it's a shame so
many of us don't know what's possible
because we never get to experience like
right now I'm in Cabo San
Lucas I'm at the bill Cortez at Pia the
one and only M Pia hotel and they have
this house here it's a five bedroom five
or six bedroom house and we come here a
couple times a year this is our second
time to be here and it's just fantastic
big infinity pool jacuzzi over here
seating areas for probably you could
entertain 25 people out here which we've
done both times we've come we've had
people guests out here business meetings
and I just didn't know when I was
growing up what was possible cuz I grew
up in a in
a you know uh single mom struggling
trying to figure out how to make it how
we could just pay the bills so there was
nobody to like create imagination about
possibility and and I hope hopefully
this channel if you find this
inspirational just walking around
looking at this place cuz you guys can
have this anybody can have this I'm
telling you you can dream big enough
line align yourself with the right
people never quit on the dream I'm
telling you believe it or not and and
maybe if you're beat up right now in
life you don't believe anything's
possible but I promise you if you don't
quit surround yourself with the right
people and can actually see the dream
see what's possible then you can
actually start planning what you need to
do who you need to meet what you need to
know since I was 13 years old I have
been trying to find my way I've been
trying to find my way to this word right
here to my dreams how do I make my
dreams a reality so like every day like
I know this what I pay attention to I
end up getting you guys ever done that
before where you're like you're riding a
bike or something and you're like I
don't want to hit that hole I don't want
to hit that crack I don't want to hit
that crack I don't want to hit that
crack I don't want to hit that rock I
don't want to hit that thing I don't
want to hit that thing and next thing
what bang you fall down you hit the
thing one thing I do every day and I'm
telling you a little trick in life if
you pay attention to something enough
whether it's good or bad it's going to
become a reality so when I wake up in
the morning what I do every day rather
than just ending up with some life
whatever the leftovers are whatever
whatever you get I don't want to just
like get what I get I want to get what I
want how many of you want to get what
you want okay so when I was 10 years old
I lost my dad my dad passed away when I
was 10 years old and it left me with my
mom my twin brother my older brother and
two sisters I was the youngest of five
there was seven of us in a small house
and the other thing that was in our
house was one other thing maybe you guys
know what this thing is I tell you what
I'll pay $100 if you know the other
person that lived at our house it's a
four-letter word boom that's right give
this man the $100 give this man the $100
right
here okay okay the school that pays
every day so check it out so check it
out so fear you have you guys ever
experienced fear in your house man I was
in fear all the every day I and and the
fear made me sad because I could see my
mom was scared I didn't know know enough
to be scared I could just tell from my
mom my mom was scared because my dad had
passed and she didn't know how she was
going to take care of the family and at
that moment one of my dreams or goals I
really like the word goals better than
dreams one of my goals became hey I
don't want to live in fear every
day I don't want to have fear every day
I want to have freedom from Fear first
thing I did was oh I screwed up here
when I thought I was good second thing
is I I got to realize what what did I do
wrong I have to figure out what what is
the thing I did wrong I identified that
and what I did wrong was uh uh I I went
too small so when I wrote the 10x rule
when I wrote that book you
showed um or talked about I I I'm like
oh I get it I I I I needed 10 Industries
I was I had one company that paid me
money I had one industry that paid me
two companies that that basically could
go out and get it and then I dumped it
into real estate the two businesses were
both slaughtered I mean slaughtered bro
like one day they were doing great the
next day they literally could not pay
bills right and I was not part of the
mortgage crisis I would had nothing to
do with the mortgage crisis I did not
buy a bunch of houses the 200 units that
I had actually and the shopping center
actually cash flowed me through the
collapse wow so so when I wrote this
this book was not really written for
other people I was literally trying to
figure out what what am I going to do to
get a bigger audience how am I going to
scale to other Industries right so back
then we had we talked to one industry
every day and uh which was automotive
and Today Automotive was literally 100%
of all my Revenue Today Automotive is
less than 1% of my Revenue if you come
up short on your goals set them higher
most of us fail when it comes to goal
setting we come up short of what we
wanted fail High rather than setting too
low a Target in the beginning I made
this mistake my whole career my entire
career number one biggest mistake was I
went for a Target that was too low so to
become a millionaire set your target at
becoming a multi-millionaire I would say
10 or even 20 if you can think that big
never quit never settle the super
financially successful don't stop once
they hit their targets they simply reset
and go again they also don't quit when
they have setbacks they recalibrate and
invest in the direction they're they're
going knowing that their goals are
attainable their goals their new goals
are important and their new goals are
worthy as long as they don't quit the
truth is I have the companies that I
have today because I was willing to get
hard I was willing to get hard okay I'm
willing to literally risk
relationships to do the right thing
people say man the right thing is never
the hard thing to do that's not true the
right thing is almost always the hard
thing to
do the right thing is almost always the
hardest thing to do yesterday I had to
call this dude hey man look I love you
like a brother dude I know you want this
deal I know you need this deal I know
this deal you guys and your team worked
hard on it I know you're relying on this
deal I know this deal literally helps
your family you're not getting the
deal it was hard dude it was hard but
the hard thing if I did the deal I'd
feel bad about myself I would have known
that I did the wrong thing for my
investors I got all these investors
depending on Grant to make the right
decision do the right thing negotiate
the best deal I got all these investors
depending on me and then I got my buddy
over here that wants the deal okay he's
got kids too man he's got family to feed
and everything and by the way I agreeed
to do the deal with him listen to this I
agreed to do the deal with him I am now
being torn apart between my social my my
my
moral agreement I agreed to do the deal
and this moral other obligation to these
people when I got all the data together
I'm like oh the my friend's deal is not
as good as this other guy did I really
like to get rid I really like to not do
anything else with him I'm not getting
what I want from this other guy but the
deal is
better this is where you got to make the
hard decision everybody wants to be the
boss baby everybody wants to go to
heaven nobody wants to
die everybody wants to be the boss
nobody wants to make the hard decision
which is typically the right thing to do
and it stirs everybody up but you told
me I know I did man and I told all these
people and I told myself and I told my
dreams bro you're not getting a deal
sorry and the faster you do the hard
thing the better off it is the stronger
you're going to get and the more the
people around you are going to start
doing the right thing because you made
it this far a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Gary V motivation check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there watch look for it but
whatever you do cut out 1 hour of
negativity add 1 hour of positivity if
you're listening right now and you're
like H social is such a drag it's
because you're in a drag mindset and the
alos and the people you follow